to become rich or famous as a man is to
accept being a resource to be extracted
from or an object to be desired I was
talking to Tucker about this and he said
women become objectified as soon as they
become like womanly you're 13 years old
and the boys in the class now start to
see that you've got boobs and then you
become like 17 18 and the whole world
objectifies you for a while because your
value is immediate and upfront this is a
red pill takeaway I guess that like
women are born with value men have to
create it unless you're Brad Pit you
have to achieve some degree of
self-generated value in order for people
to objectify no one's just objectifying
the random dude in the street but if the
random dude in the street gets out of a
Bugatti maybe they are